- All you do is talk to me.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Let me hear you
just talk so I can see how--
- Hello.
- [Mark] Perfect, okay, good.
All right, Momo.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Momo, where'd you grow up?
- [Momo] I grew up in
Los Angeles, California.
- South Central?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents growing up?
- All right, my childhood.
My father, he lives in Alabama.
My mother, she lives out here.
I grew up with my mom.
I moved from Alabama when I was a baby.
I never, I still haven't
seen my dad to this day.
I get to see him if I'm on video call,
or a chat, or anything.
- [Mark] So your dad's not
really a big part of your life?
- No, but he sends me money every month.
But I put it in my savings
account with my mom,
But, uh-uh, that's not working out.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- My child-
- How old are you?
- I'm 14.
- [Mark] You're 14, so
you're still a child.
- Yes, yeah, still a child.
- [Mark] (laughing) How is your childhood?
- It's hard.
Well, I can't say it's
hard but it's difficult.
- [Mark] What kind of
pressures do you have
as a 14 year old growing up
in 2020 in South central?
- It's good, it's all right,
but it's not all that good.
It's not good 'cause when I go back home
I gotta go on the street
and go ho and stuff.
When I'm at school,
it's a whole different person, you know?
And people don't know like that.
And I don't have friends like that.
I don't talk to people like that school.
So it's just like--
- [Mark] So they're no
other friends of yours
at school that are doing this?
- No, my friends, I don't know about them.
I just go to school.
But I go to school away from my home.
I go to school, I go to high school.
- [Mark] Oh, so, you go
school far away from home?
- Yes, I don't go to school
by home because if I go--
- [Mark] What got you
attracted to this lifestyle?
- When I was younger I was living
with my granny on 46th and Budlong.
She used to do drugs and everything.
I was embarrassed by her
because she would come outside
and I was already old
enough to know things.
I was like 11, 10, yeah.
I was already knowing
about stuff like that.
'Cause my uncles, they come
in the house with guns,
and money, all type of stuff.
And my granny, she would do drugs
at the middle of the night,
but in the morning she'd be regular.
But at nighttime, she would
come back to a whole new person.
But in the morning, she'd wake up
in the morning off of drugs.
I remember she had run outside.
I'm not trying to cry,
But she run outside, and then
all her clothes would be off.
Like everything.
My friends used to be able to see it all.
And I used to be like, dang,
like she'll come outside,
and naked, naked talking
about there's a snake on her,
there's a snake on her.
And I'd be like, no, it's
like, I tell my friends,
every time I go outside,
some of my friends,
oh, she just be tripping,
she got a problem, or stuff.
She have a medical problem and stuff.
And I tell him that and
she'll come back in the house.
But she like, she was going crazy on us
and said it's a snake on her,
all the time in the kitchen.
And we used to be like,
it's not a snake on her.
My mom started telling me
about she do drugs and stuff.
And that's why I started
knowing about drugs.
But I didn't put myself to
it until I met my boyfriend,
until met this boyfriend.
And then this is when
I was in eighth grade.
Eighth grade, I met a boyfriend.
And he was like, how old was he?
19, yes, he was 19.
And I was 13, yeah, 13.
And then, everyday, he'll come get me,
every day after school.
But he never, he was acting real nice.
He was real nice when I
first met him, real nice.
Like a regular boyfriend.
But I didn't know anything
about boyfriends and stuff
until he he told me he liked
me and he wanted to date me.
So after that, that's
when I went to school.
One day, he came and got me after school
and he was telling me about Figueroa
and how girls would be out there.
But I lived, after I moved
from 46th and Budlong,
we went to Vegas, but we came back to LA.
And then, we was off Fig and 75th.
This was where my granny used to live.
And we used to always stay with her.
Me and my mom and my
sister stayed with her.
And then that's when he
came and got me one day.
But I'm already knowing about Fig
because I live on Fig and 75th.
- So you see it.
- Yes.
I see everything out there.
I walk to the corner store
where my cousins get food and I see girls.
So I felt like I was like,
oh, they say they make money.
So I'm in my head before he even came in
before I even met him,
I'm already knowing about,
oh, it's Fig, it's a lot
of girls that be out there.
They make a lot of money.
So I'm wanting to do it.
So I'm in my head wanting to do it.
My cousin's like, don't do that.
I didn't listen to them.
I'm like, I don't care about
what y'all talking about.
So this is why I met him.
And then he was telling me
about Fig and everything.
So that's when he had told me, look,
I was walking to school with
another boy, but I wasn't like,
I didn't know nothing about
boyfriend or girlfriend.
I wasn't trying to be on a weird stuff,
trying to be with another boy.
I was walking with the
other boy and he socked me
in front of all my friends, like literally
in front of all my friends and
I was crying and everything.
And then he, I was walking
outside so I called my mom,
but I couldn't call my mom
in a hurry so he put me
in a car and telling
me, oh, you're gonna go
on Figueroa and you gonna ho for me.
You're gonna give me back
the money, everything.
So I'm just thinking like, what can I do?
I can't tell my Mama everything.
So I just did it.
I went out there and when
I did it, I was so scared.
But I wasn't too scared to the point
I couldn't do it, but I was scared.
Like I just got socked
in front of my friends.
So they're gonna probably come back to me
telling me stuff like,
what's going on with you?
Like they gonna, you know, how people be.
So then when I went
out there, I was scared
but I got two guys, like two guys.
And then they wanted me to
suck their dick and stuff.
So I did that.
But then I only got a little bit of money.
Like, how much do we have, like, $50?
I have $50.
And I didn't know nothing about Figueroa
and none of that stuff.
So I came back to him.
He saw me, he came and got me.
But I realized he had other
girls working for him.
So I'm looking at them and
they was calling my name.
But I didn't know, like, I never met them.
I guess he talked to them about me.
So I went to them and they was telling me,
oh, he gonna get mad at you.
Don't give him that.
Don't give him $50.
He gonna beat you.
And I didn't listen to them.
So I just went in the car
and he started beating me.
I went back home the same
day after he dropped me off.
He dropped me off on the
corner and he was like,
tomorrow, I'm gonna come get you again.
And I was like, uh-uh,
I'm thinking in my head,
no, I'm scared and stuff.
I ain't gonna tell him my mom.
So I came back home, but I
was still, I was bleeding.
My eye was bruised, my nose was busted
and my lip was busted.
And I went in the house
and I had told my mom
I got into a fight with a girl,
so she wouldn't think I was out there.
But I was surprised
that they didn't see me
'cause we live on the same street.
So that's when he came and got
me the same day after school.
I catch the bus to go to school by myself.
And he'll come get me after.
He'll be out there just posted in front
of my school, post out of nowhere.
And my friends would be
like looking and stuff.
And I would just be like, oh yeah,
it's just my friend this is my friend.
And they was like, no, 'cause
he socked you the other day.
And I was, I just stopped talking.
I broke it off with all my friends.
I didn't have no more friends after that
because they found, they was like,
uh-uh, she's not listening to us.
So that's when he kept having
me go out on the street.
But I kept coming back
with a little bit of money.
Cause I didn't know, until the girls,
I started listening to the girls.
They was telling me, I came back
with a little bit of money
and he beat me again.
Like he was just beating me.
- So you were working Figueroa every--
- Yes, everyday, basically.
Yes, after school.
He would give me some clothes to put on.
He would give me some clothes.
He would go to the trunk
and get me some clothes
and some sandals and that's
how I be wearing sandals.
- [Mark] What do you think
got you into this doing?
- Because I started seeing
other females on Fig.
- [Mark] It was seeing
other girls do this?
- Yes and that what made me want to do it.
- [Mark] And then you got involved in him
and he turned out to be a pimp.
- Yeah, that's crazy how God works.
Because that's crazy
how I was looking at it.
Like, oh yeah, I should do that.
- How much money were you making?
- Then, out of nowhere, when
I really started knowing
about how much money I'm supposed to make,
I was making like $200,
$300, $400 one day, $500.
About that amount, $200 to $500.
That's how much money I was making.
- [Mark] You were how old?
- Yes, oh, you said, how old?
- How old were you then?
- I was 13, yes, 13, working.
- [Mark] And you're still doing it at 14.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Are you working
with a pimp still?
- No, I'm not working with
the same pimp no more.
I thought, cause he, one
day, what day was that?
He came and got me and he was like, oh,
I'm gonna be moving somewhere
and all type of stuff.
Talking about making up
lies, just making up lies.
I'm already know he lying.
Talking about how I'm moving,
I'm not gonna see you no more.
So then I started thinking to myself,
I'm gonna make the money by myself.
So now I'm working by myself.
Just make any money by
myself because he left.
So I don't know what happened to him.
- [Mark] And your mom
doesn't step in and say--
- Yes, my mom steps in all the time.
That's what hurt me, break my heart.
It breaks my heart because she step in
and telling me to stop.
And I will stop, but
I'm addicted to it now.
So I can't stop.
- [Mark] 'Cause I met your mom
and she wants the best for you.
- Yeah, my granny, too.
Everybody do.
- [Mark] Yeah, your whole family.
- My auntie, she do it.
So I feel like I'm
comfortable with doing it.
But I'm not because Mama told me to stop.
I've been trying to stop lately.
But yesterday I stopped,
like, I didn't go yesterday.
Like I just stopped.
I just stopped going for like a week.
Like this week, I stopped going.
But yesterday, I went out at nighttime,
but I came back in the house.
But I didn't make no money or nothing.
I just came back in the house.
- [Mark] What kinda guys pick you up?
- It was some Mexican guy.
It was a Mexican guy and a black guy.
- [Mark] But the guys are nice to you,
or they're mean to you?
- No.
One of them was nice but
he was trying to force me
to do stuff with him that I
didn't want to do with him.
But I did it.
And then I was feeling bad.
But he didn't give me no money.
So I just walked in the
house and I was just crying
and every type of stuff,
I was just crying.
- [Mark] It's a very dangerous lifestyle.
- Yeah, it really is.
- [Mark] What do you think
about your self worth or your--
- I feel like I shouldn't do it but--
- [Mark] But what makes it
okay in your head to do it?
- I don't know.
Seeing other girls on the
street and I just feel like--
- [Mark] Do you look up to them?
- Yeah, I just feel like
I should do it like that.
Yeah, and I'm addicted to
it and I need to, yeah.
- [Mark] There's something very attractive
about the lifestyle for young women.
- Yeah, it is, it is.
It's attractive of attention.
A lot of people see you.
It's like, this is the attention.
Really, to me, I feel
like this is attention.
When they look at me, I'll be like, oh.
I'm insecure, myself.
I feel like I'm not beautiful.
I don't think I'm cute
or nothing like that.
I try.
And then when I'm out there, it's like,
people come to me and all type of stuff.
And they say I'm beautiful
and all type of stuff.
And that, it makes me happy.
I get it from my family, too.
But I don't feel the same
way, how I feel out there.
You know?
- [Mark] Your dad's not giving it to you.
- My dad, yeah, I don't
know have my dad in my life.
My sister's dad died and I just feel like,
I don't got no father figure.
I just feel like he
was just a sperm donor.
That's how I feel at the end of the day.
- [Mark] If you had a dad,
you probably wouldn't
be doing this, right?
- Yeah, Mama told me that, too.
She was like, if he was in your
life, you would not do this.
But he gives me money for my love.
You know how people give you
money just for just that.
But that's how I feel like
outside on the street.
They give me money just for that.
Just to have sex and do all that stuff.
And my dad just gives me money just for
he can act like he love me.
He don't, he just gives me money.
Every time I call him, he act
like he want to talk to me.
He don't wanna talk to me.
The first thing he says,
oh, do you need some money?
So that's where I, that's
how I get money hungry.
And I just want to start
asking for more money.
But still, I feel like I'm still there.
Like, if I could be able
to save my money up,
then I could be able to
do other things in life.
I do hair.
I always do people hair.
I'll do people hair on the street.
I'll do ho's hair all the time.
They come to my house
and I'll do their hair.
Mama be looking like,
Mama be disappointed,
but I'm doing hair for money.
She'll take the money
and put it up for me.
I appreciate Mom for that.
'Cause I still got money put
up at the end of the day,
if I don't have no money in the world.
- [Mark] You ever been arrested?
- Yes, plenty of times.
Heck yes, plenty of times.
- [Mark] What do the cops
do with a 14-year-old girl
who's working the streets?
- They took me home.
They didn't take me to jail.
They never take me to jail.
They always take me home.
But they said that it's gonna
affect me when I get older,
because I got all these
jail warnings and stuff.
And it's gonna affect me.
But we've been to the county building.
They said that they gonna let me, like,
I'm not on probation, nothing like that.
They just said they
gonna try to work with me
and try to tell me to stop doing this.
Because I got arrested, how many times,
five times for prostituting
'cause they caught me
on the street with other
girls and they'd come get us.
And I remember I was actually
arrested when I was 13.
I used to hang out with my friends
and we used to go driving around in cars.
But they didn't have license, you know?
And we shouldn't be driving.
And one day, I was driving a
car and then I got pulled over.
I went to the thing
but I didn't go to jail 'cause I'm young.
They just always take me home.
But every time I go to the
county building, I mean, not the
county building, the court
place, they tell me everything.
They say I need to work on it
because when I get older,
it could affect me.
I could be in jail for more
than what I think or whatever.
So, yeah, that's what's going on.
- [Mark] Are drugs a part of your life?
- Yes.
You said drugs?
- Yeah.
- Yes, I've been on drugs before.
When I was 14, after he had put me
in his car and everything,
he was telling me to try
crack cocaine, crack.
And I tried crystal, too.
I already smoked weed.
When I was 13, I never
smoked stuff like that,
until I met him.
- [Mark] 'Cause your pimp was giving you--
- Yes, he was giving me drugs.
And that's another thing that
made me think that I was okay.
Because I was doing drugs
and the drugs take over me.
And I would be out there acting crazy.
One day he gave me,
what's that, it's acid.
You take it.
And I was so, that day I was so happy.
I was just making a lot of money.
I was just with my friends.
And one day I had did a threesome
with my other two friends.
And I was thinking,
uh-uh, I was so scared.
That day I went home, I just went home.
- [Mark] And there are other
girls your age doing this?
- Yes, like 13, yes, 12.
There's a girl I know that's 12.
But I think she lying.
I don't know if she 12 or I don't know.
I can't believe nobody out there, really.
I can't trust nobody out there.
'Cause I don't know.
'Cause one day I got into,
I got jumped one day by a couple of girls
because they said that I was looking at
their pimp or something like that.
But their pimp actually was looking at me.
He was trying to have me go with them.
I got jumped one day and
that's the day I got,
you see this scar right here on my face?
There's a scar, right here.
But it was deep.
They kicked me in my face.
I went to the hospital
and I had bumps on my head, everything.
And that's after I stopped.
'Cause I started getting scared.
I was like, uh-uh, I'm not
trying to get out there
and get jumped no more and stuff.
But I was just going with the flow.
I was just going with it
and I just kept doing it.
And I was just like, and I
feel like it took over me.
But I still did my hair.
But it take over me.
Like I can't even do the things
I want to do with my friends
'cause I wanna go on the street so bad.
That don't make no sense to me.
- You wanna do it?
- Yeah, I wanna do it.
- [Mark] Something draws you to it.
- Yeah, but--
- You get depressed sometimes?
- Yeah, heck yes, believe me.
I get depressed but I try not
to let that take over me, too.
I'll just be sitting there
like, stop worrying about that.
Or I'll go get some weed.
My sister will take me to the weed shop
and I'll be calm, I'll be okay.
I feel like when I smoke week,
it takes everything away.
You know?
I don't gotta worry about nothing.
But I still be worrying about it.
But I don't gotta worry
about it like as much
as I worry about it when
I'm not not off weed.
- [Mark] As a young teen, are
there things that you dream
about doing in life?
- Yes, a lot of things.
- [Mark] Something that,
goals that you have?
- [Momo] In the hair shop,
being in a hair shop.
Me braiding hair.
I do hair all the time.
It started out five customers.
I'll always do hair.
I'm working up to get a YouTube.
I'm working up to get a
camera to have me a YouTube
so I can do hair because
I see a lot of people
on YouTube that do hair.
And I'm good at my skill.
I'm good at doing hair.
I just did my Mama hair.
I did all their hair.
And yeah, I do my granny hair, everything.
I'm working on learning how to do haircut.
You see how my granny's hair is trimmed?
I'm working on how to do that.
But I know how to braid and everything.
I braid hair.
- [Mark] So that would be a career for you
that you could actually feel
good about what you're doing.
Whereas, working Figueroa
probably does the opposite.
- [Momo] Yeah, it's just
hard being out there.
It's just hard.
Like, dang.
It's like, you gotta work up
to get the money and everything.
I feel like me not having a pimp
is better for me, not having a pimp.
Because I get to have the
money at the end of the day.
Nobody gonna pimp me and beat me around,
like how it used to happen and stuff.
I'm not about that stuff.
- [Mark] Do you think you're
addicted to the lifestyle?
- [Momo] Yeah, yes, I
really think I'm addicted
and I'm trying to stop.
- [Mark] I've heard that from other girls.
- Yes, I think I'm trying,
I've been trying so bad
but it's not working.
But I trust myself.
I trust that when I turn,
at least like, 17 or 16,
I'll stop because some
people, they learn from 17.
They start doing it around 16.
I know girls that told me
that they've been doing
around 16, 17, and they
stopped at 20 or 21.
Like my auntie, she has not stopped.
And that's another
thing that motivated me.
'Cause I feel like my auntie do it.
And I feel like it's okay.
But it's really not.
It's not okay.
But I think it's okay sometimes.
I'll go, okay, I don't
care what nobody think
or I'll get insecure and I
feel like I should go out
on the street and I'll get
attention or something like that.
- [Mark] So it's the
combination of the fast money,
the attention.
- Yes, I swear.
- [Mark] I'm sure it's exciting
and dangerous and all that.
- Yeah, the dangerous, I
don't really get into danger
like that, except for
the time I got jumped.
I have got shot at before.
I got shot at.
That was, oh, god, that was worse.
- [Mark] I would call that dangerous.
- My best friend, she
got shot in her leg, yep.
- [Mark] Do you ever just look, I mean,
I know you're young and
you've only been doing this
a year or so, but do you
ever look at it and go,
Jesus, this is crazy that I'm doing this?
Your friends must.
- Yes.
They always tell me to stop doing this.
It's not gonna get you nowhere.
And I understand, but the money
it's the money that get me there.
I don't be worried about the money a lot.
I worry about the attention.
- [Mark] But if you had a
dad in your life who was--
- Yes, it would be so much better
because when I get on the phone with him,
I start get to crying and stuff.
But I try and not cry.
But I cry about things I do.
But it's me.
I can't do nothing about it
until I feel like I should stop.
You know?
- [Mark] What do you
think would help you now,
at 14, to stop?
- My mom, my mom helped me.
She helped me.
Mom is my number one.
- [Mark] Yeah, you're mom's solid.
- My mama, she makes sure
like, if I go out there,
she'll be like, uh-uh, she'll
be gone if I go out there.
She would be gone.
That's the only reason
I really go out there.
She had been gone somewhere, or at work,
or something and she would be gone.
And then I'll just go out there.
And then when she come back home
she'll see something wrong with me
or I'm high off something or I'm tripping,
or I got a bruise on me, or something.
But that's before, though.
Now, I don't get bruised.
After I got jumped, I don't be talking
to females out there like that.
But I have two friends,
one of them named Brittany.
And they white, they white
girls, like straight white.
They not even like, they straight up.
But it's a man that
live on, he on Broadway.
It's a man on Broadway something.
It's a whole house.
It's a trap house.
And all of them being in there.
But I don't like going there
because the pimp, he a pimp.
His name, he be doing all type of stuff.
He a pimp.
And they be doing all type of stuff there.
And I'd be like, no, I'm not.
No, I'm not fixing to go over there.
Because one of the girls
I was friends with used to work for him.
And I would be like, whoa, like, no.
I'm not trying to deal with that stuff.
Because if I go over there it's gonna be
a lot of drama between other girls or him
trying to get me to go with them or stuff.
And I'll be like, no.
So I just stay by myself now.
Or I'll just be with my
friend, my other friend.
And we'd just be riding around, sometimes.
Yeah, like that.
When I go with my friends,
that stop me from going
on Fig a little big.
Because that give me a different life.
Me with my friends at
school and stuff, you know.
That's how I feel a little bit, yeah.
- [Mark] What do you
think would help you stop?
- What help me is
other people telling me to stop.
That's what help me to stop.
But what really help me?
I don't even know what
would help me to stop.
- [Mark] Watch some of
the videos on my channel
and see where these girls, the older--
- Watching my auntie, I was really crying.
That did like--
- [Mark] None of the older women
are saying this is a great thing.
Not that that's what's really
the cure for your situation.
I think having your dad not
around is probably the biggest.
- Yeah, that's the main thing.
'Cause I don't even get to talk to him.
And he lives way in Alabama.
That's far from LA.
And we'll try to work
our way to go out there.
But Mama, she has to pay the
bills and everything else.
But I'm saving my money to
go out there and see my dad.
'Cause my grandma, down
my granny's side, she deaf
and I wanna at least
see her before she go.
You know?
Before she go.
'Cause that's sad
because I won't be able
to see my dad's mom.
She used to hold me and everything.
So I feel bad.
So I need to go see her
because that's another person
I love in my life, like, really bad.
And my mom, she's my own dad, really.
- [Mark] Your mom's great.
I met your mom.
- On Father's Day, every
day on Father's Day,
she always wear, you know, the things
when a man wears a suit, they wear the.
What is that called?
I forgot.
- A suit and a tie.
- Yeah, the tie.
She always wear that, all the time.
She would dress like a man.
I'd be laughing and stuff.
Yeah, my granny, too.
All of them do that all the time.
- [Mark] Your mom is Bonafide's sister.
- Yeah, that's her blood sister.
My mom's the oldest out of all
my granny's kids, the oldest.
We got my uncle, my uncle live in Vegas.
He be telling me.
He don't know I really do it.
Mom be telling him, though,
because she don't want him to
get mad and stuff, you know.
'Cause he get mad.
He really aggressive.
'Cause that my granny's brother.
Yeah, that's my granny's brother
and they don't play that stuff.
So yeah.
And that's hard.
- [Mark] Your mom's doing her best.
- Yeah, she is.
My Mama's a good mother.
Out of all my mama's
siblings, half of them,
half my cousins are in the system.
So I don't barely see my cousins.
But they gonna come out.
They gonna be here.
I'm gonna be able to see them.
I see one of my other cousins.
She crazy.
Celestonia, Bonafide, one of her kids,
my cousin, she was on live one day.
And she showed her whole body on live.
And I'm like, what the freak?
And she added my auntie,
my mama's other sister.
My sister, she was crying and calling me.
And she was like, you really need to stop.
She was telling me I
need to stop being on Fig
and everything because look
what your cousin's doing.
She over here on internet showing her body
and adding her family
members and everything.
And I be trying to tell her,
I'll get my cousins shoes.
The ones they got out
there, I'll give them shoes.
'Cause that's my favorite thing,
is shoes and clothes and jewelry.
And I'll always give them stuff
because they don't got
the stuff that I got.
So I'll be like, oh, you
can have these shoes,
or you can have this chain,
or something, stuff like that.
- [Mark] Is growing up in the
hood also part of the problem?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Is growing up in
the hood part of the problem?
- Yes, that is.
It's hard because, dang,
you gotta see shooting,
you gotta see people fight on the street,
you gotta see people trying to, it's crazy
'cause you gotta do all
types of stuff in the hood.
You gotta see people trying to get at you.
It's too much stuff, it's too much stuff.
People will want to fight
you over just dumb stuff.
Haters.
It's all type of stuff over there.
But I can't do nothing about
it because that's where I live.
Where else am I gonna be at?
- [Mark] No, you're not growing
up in a nice neighborhood.
You drive down Figueroa.
What are you gonna see?
- What am I supposed to see?
What am I supposed to do?
- [Mark] (chuckling) You're
gonna see pimps and prostitutes.
- Yeah.
And I go to my friends,
I have this one friend,
her uncle is a Ressel Warbrick.
What's his name?
He a basketball player.
- Russell Westbrook.
- Yes and I went with her to his house.
I've been to famous people's house.
I been to his house.
I've been to Kaylan Frista's.
He a rapper, for real, for real.
I've been to a lot of people.
But, yeah, but I don't let that get to me.
But I like that life.
I get to see--
- You're a very smart girl.
For your age, you're
very smart and mature.
But at some point,
you need to figure out
how to change direction.
And you're even talented, you know?
You have things you could be doing.
But I can tell ya, as an outsider,
some white dude that's got
some nice cameras (chuckling),
you're making a mistake
by following that life.
- Yeah, I'm trying to, yeah,
really trying to stop, yeah.
But every time I think about it,
I'll think about it like I'm gonna stop.
But when I see somebody else out there,
it make me want to go out there.
And then I'll come back
in the house sometimes.
I'll be like, I'm not
fixing to keep doing this
but it's still affects me.
Still, at the end of the
day, it's gonna affect me.
And I'll try to stop but.
I get it from my mom, everybody.
But because I grew up
around stuff like that.
So I can't change my life.
I'm making me a whole new person.
But I can because in the
future, what am I gonna do?
What am I gonna do?
So I gotta change my life.
So, yeah, that's all I've
been thinking, really, yeah.
- [Mark] Well, Momo, I
hope you figure this out
and change your direction.
'Cause you're such a lovely, young girl
and it'd be great to
see you just figures out
at a young age and make
the right decision.
- Right.
- [Mark] I hope you figure that out.
All right, thank you for coming in.
- Mm-hmm.
- All right.
- Oo, I just cried a lot.
- [Mark] Oh, it's okay.
- I like when I cry though
'cause it makes me feel better.
- [Mark] Oh, for sure.
- Yeah, it make me feel so much better.
'Cause I feel like crying is better.
I have to deal with.
I try.
I feel you like my dad.
I don't know, I see you
as my dad, right now.
- [Mark] Call me.
Treat me like your dad.
I'll give you great advice
that your dad should have.
- [Momo] 'Cause I see you as my real dad.
For real.
I don't know why but I see you as my dad.